in this project we're going to be doing
infinite terrain generation and we'll be
doing that by building on and extending
the previous tutorials with a quadtree
and level of detail in movies you often
see these long dramatic shots showing
off huge landscapes and if you want to
be able to convey that same sense of
scale and your own game scene you need
to be able to draw a lot of stuff all
the way out to the horizon or even
further depending on the game you're
making in the past couple tutorials we
covered implementation of basic height
maps before moving on to understanding
how to generate noise and calculate
fractional Brownian motion to improve
the quality of our 3d world generation
now we're adding on infinite procedural
terrain and level of detail so that we
can draw pretty much as much as we want
I'll start with a single piece of
terrain from the last tutorial what we
need to do is work towards extending
this to entire landscapes to begin what
we want to do is update the terrain
based on where the camera is and I did
that by creating this terrain chunk
manager that checks the cameras position
each frame so that as we move around and
outside the bounds of that chunk of
terrain we generate a new chunk of
terrain and as I do that you can see the
new one that's closer to the camera sort
of pops into existence the next step to
making this more infinite is that
instead of just generating a single
chunk of terrain around the camera we
can generate a whole bunch so we figure
out which terrain chunk we're in and
then proceed to generate all the
surrounding ones as well and once you
start moving around it gives you a bit
more sense of limitless since it doesn't
matter how far you can go in any
direction will just generate more and
more terrain but this is really limited
because I can't keep extending this if I
want to just draw a few kilometers to
the horizon the number of tiles is
squared and I need about a hundred and
that's just at eye level if I want a
further out shot that I can see about
let's say 20 kilometers suddenly I need
1,600 this is getting out of hand really
quickly what I ended up doing was
implementing a quadtree now if you're
not familiar with this data structure
it's a way of partitioning
two-dimensional space by dividing it
recursively into four smaller quadrants
hence the quad part now I didn't see
that many good
tutorials in this so this is how I got
it to work what you do is you set up a
root node which is the area you want the
quadtree to cover and then you insert
the camera into the tree beginning at
the root node you check the distance
from the center of the node to the
camera and if it's less than some
threshold in my case I use whether the
distance from the center of the node was
less than the width of the node times
sort of a multiplier if it's too close
then we go ahead and split the node
creating four children and you can see
here that the way we create the children
is pretty straightforward just bottom
left bottom right top left and top right
at that point we recurse and do the
exact same thing in each of these
children so for each child we check
whether or not they're close to the
camera if they're not we do nothing and
if they are we split and create four
more children and so on until we decide
the nodes are too small at which point
we can also stop back to our terrain
chunk manager what I do is every frame I
create a quad tree and then insert the
cameras position into it after that I go
and get every single leaf node that is
every node that has no children under it
then we compare that list of terrain
chunks so the ones that we already have
everything that already exists great we
don't need to generate those ones all
the new ones we create new terrain
chunks for those which will then build
the mesh and color the vertices that
needed and once we do that Walla
we have terrain stretching out for 32
kilometers in every direction as I move
around you can see the terrain is a bit
fuzzy and low resolution in the distance
but as we move it gets smoother and
higher resolution from the top here
you've got a bit of a better view the
white ball is supposed to be where the
camera is and you can see how the
terrain gets progressively less detailed
as you get further away after the camera
of pan slowly over the landscape details
closer to the camera come in also note
that we don't require that many chunks
of trained to render this pretty massive
scene dropping a breakpoint in the
terrain chunk manager we can see that
the quadtree only gives us 70 children
that means that there's only 70 chunks
of terrain that we needed to generate
for this entire scene
again looking at this from way above in
wireframe mode we can see that there's a
lot of resolution closer to the camera
but it falls off quickly and when you're
on the ground yeah maybe you can see it
if you're looking for it but we're
putting the resources where they matter
where they should be up close to the
camera and if we were to tried to do
this with a thick sized grid like we
started with it will require well each
terrain chunk is 500 meters by 500
meters so that's 16,000 terrain chunks
this isn't quite done yet at least not
for now because you may have noticed how
the scene stuttered heavily as we moved
and it had to generate the new terrain
this is caused by the creation of all
those new chunks of terrain even though
there aren't that many there are still a
few and doing them all at once is
causing a slowdown so what I did here
was I went ahead and created this
terrain junk builder class and what this
does is that you give it a list of
terrain chunks that you need built and
it'll spread the creation of them over
multiple frames each of the terrain
chunks has a rebuild function and I
converted that into a generator and that
lets me spread the generation of the
terrain over multiple frames doing a
little bit at a time so what we do is
focus on generating one chunk of terrain
at a time and when that's done it gets
removed from the list and we start
working on the next one
eventually when they're all complete we
swap the old ones and new ones all at
once and the new stuff appears the other
thing that helped was keeping a pool of
terrain chunks handy so that we didn't
have to instantiate new ones all the
time but instead we reused old ones you
can see here that after we generate the
new ones we recycle the old ones and
those go into a pool whenever we create
a chunk of terrain we simply call create
terrain chunk with the parameters that
we need and that checks whether or not
we already have a pre-built one if it
does great he uses it otherwise it
instantiates a new one and passes it
back now there's a few better ways we
could do this that we could work on next
maybe in a future project like instead
of using generator functions we could
thread this work off into workers we
could also skip generating any of this
on the CPU and move this right into
vertex shaders or even compute shaders
if they're available
there's a lot of options for improvement
here and so there we have it a quadtree
implementation that gives us effectively
an infinite procedural world source code
is all available on github so fork it
and go ahead and tweak it or do whatever
you want with it I'll be continuing this
tutorial series in the future so look
out for the next one make sure to hit
like and subscribe and I'll see you next
time Cheers
you